sticky
put yourself
[Music]
Anna is learning to live in darkness
after Russian attacks against Ukraine's
Power and Water Supplies created a new
front line in people's homes
in her apartment in Kiev she stores
emergency supplies and improvisers with
blankets to keep food warm
at 91 Anna even claims Russia's cruelty
is worse than the horrors of World War
II
Hitler well
despite the hardship she's not giving up
foreign
foreign
weeks of Russian missile strikes have
turned off the lights across much of the
country in an attempt to break people's
will to resist
but the British foreign secretary on his
first trip to Ukraine said Vladimir
Putin will fail
James cleverly spoke as he visited a
school on the outskirts of Kiev that
will reopen next week after UK money
helped to repair damage from the war
he is trying to starve and freeze the
ukrainians into submission what I've
also seen is those same ukrainians
forcing uh forcing themselves to go
about their lives as normally as
possible
and yet it relies on a different kind of
warrior to endure
miraslava has melted snow to wash with
and when the power goes she wraps her
children in coats to keep them warm yeah
um
foreign
[Music]
the hardest to defeat
Deborah Haynes Sky News Kiev